[Musique]
lequel de ces deux fromages est une
mozzarella les deux la mozzarella
fraîche seaux fromages blancs à pâte
molle qu'on vend qu'il fait chaud à base
de lait de vache veau de lait de
bufflonne puis en le vendant de l'eau ou
dans la saumure c'est quelque chose qui
est censé être consommés frais dans son
état assez frileux quelques semaines au
maximum après sa production versus la
moto est là qu on achète en épicerie y
est sous forme de briques ou râper dans
des grands sacs avec une texture
beaucoup plus différente
à la teneur en humidité c'est vraiment
le gros point de différenciation donc la
matériel à frêche c'est un fromage qui
est plus humide donc la texture va être
beaucoup plus molle beaucoup plus
onctueuse le goût et est plus délicat
tandis que le moteur est là qu'on va
appeler disons est régulière et plus
sèche donc le goût est un petit qui
prononce un peu plus à l'est ce qui fait
en sorte que le brunissement va se faire
un petit peu mieux ce soit un petit peu
plus prudent parce que la teneur en
humidité est moins élevé bien on peut la
garder sur les tablettes un peu plus
longtemps
moi j'étais jeune je travaille ici
c'était
mario zurini est propriétaire de la
friterie milano a promis ce temps là moi
c'est comme si moi j'ai fait tout un
morceau de jambe à naître et qu'on vend
dès la maternelle au tout début après
son
avion c'est sûr qu'en italie ça fait des
années et des années qu'ils ont
plusieurs choix quand on tente de
mozzarella patricia au couteau de la bd
fromage se spécialise dans l'importation
des fromages d'italie la mozzarella di
buffala ça fait depuis le 16e siècle qui
en produisent en italie alors c'est
vraiment une tradition qui date depuis
très très longtemps
les derniers 10 15 ans on en voit de
plus en plus grâce à l'importation de
produits par ces produits le lait
mozzarella fraîche qui viennent de
l'italie arrivent par avion pour que ça
arrive vraiment frais
pour les italiens la mozzarella de
bufflonne c'est vraiment ce produit
qu'on mange quotidiennement
c'est quelque chose qu'on va chercher à
tous les jours on en mange presque à
tous les jours alors peut-être à ce
niveau là oui ça se compare à
[Musique]
mozzarella fior di latte et des bouffes
à la burrata bocconcini des noms qui
évoquent l'italie bien sûr mais quelles
en sont les différences amateurs et leur
fera ch on la retrouve sous deux formes
soit faite à base de lait de bufflonne
savait toujours indiquer si on la
retrouve sous le nom de fioles du lartet
dans le fond en tennis ça laisse la
traduction pour flore de l'est ça c'est
un produit à base de lait de vache
ensuite on parle de beaucoup ont fini
puis beaucoup en chine est la traduction
c'est bouché donc on parle de boucher de
notre saper la fraîche donc là on a
vraiment le même processus plus ou moins
que la mozzarella puis différentes
déclinaisons l'antenne de brossard on en
trouve plusieurs différentes tailles la
burrata c'est une enveloppe de
mozzarella fraîche et puis à l'intérieur
il y à un mélange de crème et des petits
morceaux de mozzarella fraîche alors
cette crème et 7 mozzarella fraîche et
un rhdp est enveloppé par un sac de
mozzarella fraîche qu'on enveloppe voilà
on a deux laboratoires
les restaurants italiens nous ont
d'abord fait connaître le mariage des
tomates et beaucoup de chimie un mois de
ça rien 5 août meilleure qu'en se
déchirer avec les doigts vanessa nous
propose de bien belle et bonne façon de
mettre en valeur toutes les formes de
mozzarella en cuisine
pour l'amateur et leur un beau
changement aux tomates pendant l'été et
c'est de combiner ça avec des pages
grillé donc on fait qu'après sa base de
page ça permet justement de pas masquer
le fromage mais vraiment juste de le
rehausser une idée avec ses fromages
frais là on va quand même garder c'est
assez simple pour pas à rajouter trop de
chaleur parce que ça ça va venir changer
la texture place avant tout c'est
quelque chose qu'on voit de plus en plus
même dans les restaurants maintenant de
rajouter une touche de burrata vraiment
sur le plot fini de pâte puis vraiment
la chaleur départ de venir va ressortir
la créant dans la burrata c'est
délicieux mais en termes de recettes on
peut ajouter ça des salades des salades
de pardon une salade de pesto à laquelle
on rajoute des brunes chine et à la fin
ou une salade de plus steeple antipasto
donc avec des carreaux d'artichaut des
tomates séchées un petit peu de
radicchio on peut rajouter 100
l'intérieur donc ça passe des choses
assez simples pour pour trouver
normalement dans le garde-manger la clio
continuer ça sera ajouté très simplement
à la fenière pour ajouter une petite
touche crémant ça voilà des idées qui
met l'eau à la bouche
pour déguster la fraîcheur venu
d'ailleurs il faut être prêt à payer le
prix
évidemment ces pots données étant donné
qu'on doit le faire rentrer au canada
par avion parce que la durée de vie est
très courte
s'ajoutent au coût il ya le coût du
transport qui vient s'ajouter au coût du
produit on peut payer jusqu'à 96 dollars
le kilo pour une bataille d'alien les
entreprises canadiennes produisent aussi
des mozzarella fraîche sous diverses
formes même de la burrata et de la
mozzarella de bufflonne et les offres à
des prix souvent moins élevé
et ça se compare avec ce qu'on peut
manger en italie
ceux de bufflonne son nom
[Rires]
c'est quand même des bons produits mais
autre que l'ingrédient de base qui est
du lait de bufflonne le produit ne
votent pas nécessairement la même chose
c'est ce qu'on a c'est difficile d'avoir
un produit vraiment très très frais
d'italie donc on peut avoir un produit
délicieux tout aussi frais québécois
locale puis on peut satisfaire de
ceux-là définitivement